tout a commencé le 25 juillet lorsque
donald trump appelle le président de
l'ukraine
volodymyr zelensky élu en mai dernier
pas seulement pour le féliciter de sa
victoire comme le président américain
avait d'abord admis mais aussi pour lui
demander plusieurs fois d'enquêter sur
enter baden le fils de joe biden trump
voudrait ainsi démontré un conflit
d'intérêt chez les buy donne qui
pourrait lui servir dans l'éventuelle
campagne présidentielle il faut remonter
en 2016 quand joe biden alors vice
président s'occupe du dossier ukrainien
au sein de l'administration obama
à l'époque ils demandent que soit
congédié le procureur général d'ukraine
viktor choutkine qui est accusé de
corruption et pour ce faire ils menacent
de retenir une garantie de prêt de 1
milliard promise par les états unis à
l'ukraine face à la pression anti
corruption du peuple ukrainien et de la
pression internationale
chaque n est finalement limogé fin de
l'histoire
il faut savoir qu'en 2014 hunter baden
le fils siéger au conseil
d'administration d'une société gazière
ukrainienne but risma qui était
justement au centre d'une enquête
ouverte par shoken coïncidence trois ans
plus tard joe biden ni qu'il était au
courant du dossier de son fils en
ukraine et jusqu'ici rien ne prouve le
contraire et n'a démontré un quelconque
conflit d'intérêts mais pour donald
trump ce simple lien familial et suspect
d'où ses demandes répétées au nouveau
président ukrainien pour tenter de mêler
son rival démocrate pas de la corruption
est depuis plusieurs jours tant son
avocat rudy giuliani que trump lui même
continue d'alimenter les soupçons sur le
candidat favori à l'investiture
démocrate
mais cette stratégie se retourne
maintenant contre lui
surtout depuis qu'un lanceur d' alerte a
déposé le 12 août dernier une plainte
formelle contre le président américain
pour ses demandes répétées à une
puissance étrangère d'enquêter sur un
rival politique américain la pression de
trump aurait même été assortie d'une
menace de retrait d'une aide de 250
millions de dollars à l'ukraine
la plate auraient dû être transmises au
congrès sept jours plus tard or le
directeur du renseignement national par
intérim a refusé de le faire pour les
démocrates les actes de donald trump
dans ce dossier représente en tout cas
un motif sérieux de destitution ici
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal